من مصر مشاهدينا سالنا الناس متى تقول
للمصارع الهارب لتقنعه بالعوده الى مصر
خلينا نشوف شو
[موسيقى]
ارجع الرجوع هيكون احسن بكتير قوي حياتك
طول عمرك بره مش البطولات او الامبين اللي
انت هتحب تخشها دي الحاجه اللي هتخليك
مرتاح بعدين لا رجوعك هو اللي هيريحك وسط
اهلك واستناسك
اللي هو يحترف بره ويكون فرصته احسن عن
هنا بس هي الفكره كلها في الطريقه مثلا مش
كويسه مش مناسبه يعني هو كان ممكن يحترف
احسن من كده بيفكر في اللي اخذه ولما يرجع
ما اظنش مشكله هتبقى كبيره ممكن يقدر
يحلها تاني ويطلع بطريقه ثانيه مشرفه
تشتغل في البلد ومصر يرجع لان
اكيد وهو هناك اكيد الحياه مش هتبقى كويسه
طبعا زي هنا بالظبط
اكيد يعني ما كانش ما كانش ماشي بس برده
في نفس الوقت احنا مش عايزين نشجعوا ان هو
يمشي عشان دي بلدنا المفروض كلنا واحد هنا
وبنحبها
وكلنا برده في نفس الوقت بنقوم بيها
فالرساله المفروض تتوجه للشخص الاصلي اللي
مشاه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات